encontramos un procedimiento para
generar una base [ __ ] normal en el
último vídeo y no fue un descubrimiento
nuevo de hecho se llama el proceso de
grandes mid pero vamos a aplicarlo ahora
a ejemplos reales y con suerte veremos
que es mucho más concreto que lo que
puede para lo que pudo parecer en el
último vídeo así que vamos a empezar
partiendo digamos que tengo el plano
definido por esta ecuación x 1 + x 2 + x
3 igual a cero ok entonces ve que va a
ser nuestro espacio vectorial es el
plano el plano definido vamos a llamarlo
así el plano definido por la ecuación
anterior que es esta x 1 + x 2 + x 3
igual a 0 es decir son todos los
vectores que al sumar sus coordenadas en
r3 nos da 0 ok entonces para ir viendo
quién una base al menos aunque no sea
[ __ ] normal para ver una base de este
espacio v vamos a tomar vamos a restar x
2 y x 3 de ambos lados y nos queda
es igual a menos x 2 - x 3 ok entonces
vamos a el plano b el plano b va a ser
el conjunto de vectores digamos x 1 x 2
x 3 tales que deben ser iguales a bueno
déjenme poner esto de la siguiente forma
digamos si x 2 es igual a c 1
x 3 es igual a 2 una constante
entonces x1 es igual a menos 1 - cerdos
estoy parametrizado este plano verdad
entonces este este plano el espacio
vectorial b lo podemos escribir como
combinaciones lineales de dos vectores y
están dados por estas constantes en uno
verdad es decir vamos a multiplicarse
uno por algún vector y vamos a sumar ese
dos por algún otro vector
muy bien y de hecho x1 es menos 12
entonces
lo que tenemos que multiplicar es a x1
es menos 1 aquí es menos uno por uno
verdad y es menos uno aquí tenemos un
menos de dos entonces va a ser menos uno
aquí también la primera coordenada es x1
entonces es menos uno menos de dos ahora
vamos con la segunda coordenada x2 pues
va a ser vamos a ponerlo con este verde
x2 simplemente va a ser ese 1 entonces
aquí va un 1 pero no tiene ese 2 así que
0 y finalmente vamos a hacerlo con otro
verde x 3 que es la tercera coordenada
es sólo se dos entonces no hay c 1 y si
hay c 2 ok aquí aquí el detalle es que
c1 y c2 son números reales arbitrarias
ok entonces estamos generando este plano
con estos dos vectores con el menos 110
y el menos 10
quería entonces ve vamos a reescribir lo
de esa forma que es el espacio vectorial
generado por estos dos vectores por el
menos 110 y por el vector menos 101 ok
en estos paréntesis y de hecho si vemos
que son linealmente independientes
verdad porque si nosotros multiplicamos
este vector por alguna constante nunca
vamos a obtener este 1 porque aquí hay
un cero y al revés si nosotros
multiplicamos este vector por cualquier
constante nunca vamos a obtener este 1
ok entonces estos estos 2
estos dos vectores estos dos vectores
forman una base de nuestro espacio
vectorial b
ok entonces vamos a ponerles nombre
vamos a decir que este es b 1 y este
vamos a llamarle b 2 ok entonces estos
dos vectores son una base del espacio
vectorial b pero en realidad queremos
hallar una base [ __ ] normal estos ni
siquiera son
no no tiene ni siquiera norma 1 y de
hecho si hacemos el producto punto no
nos da 0 verdad puedes hacerlo sí sí lo
puedes hacer es este así al tanteo
puedes ver que no si no puedes tomar
papel y lápiz y hacer el producto punto
y ver que esto el producto punto de b1 y
b2 no nos da 0 entonces vamos a proceder
como en el vídeo anterior vamos a tener
vamos a empezar con b 1 el espacio
vectorial generado por el primer vector
que es b 1 esto esencialmente es una
línea en r3 verdad entonces para generar
una base corto normal de este espacio
que es de una sola dimensión
basta con dividir dividir el vector b 1
entre su norma entonces tomamos vamos a
definir a uno que es simplemente b 1
sobre la norma pero quién es la norma
debe 1 la norma la norma debe 1 no es
otra cosa más que la raíz cuadrada de la
suma de sus coordenadas al cuadrado
entonces aquí es uno más uno más en la
tercera es cero verdad entonces menos
uno al cuadrado más uno al cuadrado más
cero al cuadrado y esto es la raíz
cuadrada del número 2 entonces si
nosotros dividimos a b1 entre su norma y
su norma es raíz de 2 entonces nos queda
1 entre la raíz de 2 por el vector de
uno que es menos 11
ok este es el elemento que nos va a
formar nuestra base de orton normal
aunque solo sea de un elemento y
entonces el espacio vectorial generado
por de uno es el mismo espacio vectorial
generado que por un 1 verdad simplemente
estamos escalando este vector muy bien
entonces eso es para nuestro espacio
vectorial b 1 vámonos con el espacio
vectorial de 2 de hecho vamos a hacer un
dibujito para que sea más claro por
ejemplo aquí tenemos vamos a hacerlo un
poco más grande aquí tenemos nuestro
vector 1 1
este es nuestro vector 1 1 y el espacio
vectorial generado por 1 pues es toda
esta línea verdad toda esta línea que
estoy pintando con un punteado
que es toda esta línea y a lo mejor
tenemos por aquí a ver dos no sabemos
dijo podríamos dibujarlo pero vamos a
hacerlo más más en general no sabemos
cómo sea solo es un dibujo que nos va a
ayudar pero ve dos digamos que es de
esta forma ok entonces lo que tenemos
que hacer es reemplazar a b2 por el
vector un vector ortogonal a esta línea
y de hecho podemos obtenerlo de esta
forma verdad de esta forma si hacemos
este vector ye 2 como en el vídeo
anterior éste se encuentra en el
complemento ortogonal del espacio
generado por un 1 entonces de hecho
sabemos que de aquí que está el origen a
este punto todo esto es la proyección la
proyección sobre de uno de nuestro
vector de dos y eso sabemos calcularlo
muy bien verdad entonces lo que yo
quiero encontrar es de dos
el espacio vectorial generado por
1 1 y nuestro vector de 2 verdad y de
hecho no es lo que quiero encontrar eso
ya lo sabemos
de hecho este es el generado por b1 y b2
en principio pero ya dijimos que
cualquier cosa generado por b 1 es
generado por un 1 verdad entonces éste
también es el espacio vectorial generado
por un 1
b2b
v2 y que de hecho necesitamos en
encontrar este ye 2 para decir que es el
espacio vectorial generado por 1 1 y 2 y
eso es cierto porque de 2 más esta
proyección no sabe 2 entonces cualquier
cosa que sea generado por 1 y b 2 puede
ser generado por 1 y 2 aunque ya lo
hemos dicho varias veces y de hecho de
más aún verdad éste el espacio generado
por b1 y b2 es justamente el plano que
queremos encontrar entonces solo hay que
hacer las operaciones sólo hay que hacer
las operaciones porque sabemos encontrar
dos de dos
es igual a b2 estévez 2 - la proyección
sobre el espacio b 1 desde 2 y también
sabemos calcular muy bien esta verdad 10
b 2 es menos 1 menos 101
aquí está de 2 - vamos a restar vamos a
hacer el producto punto debe 2 con 11
entonces aquí va a ser menos 10 1 punto
y vamos a poner esto aquí 1 sobre la
raíz de 2 que es 1 x menos 110 ok aquí
está este producto punto
este producto punto de hecho este vector
de aquí es de 2 ya estamos haciendo
punto el vector 11 para encontrar la
proyección y hay que multiplicar por 1
que es 1 sobre la raíz de 2 x menos 110
ok y este es un 1 muy bien de hecho todo
esto de aquí todo esto de aquí es la
proyección sobre el espacio b 1 del
vector b 2 muy bien entonces sólo hay
que simplificar estas operaciones y ya
tendremos nuestro vector de 2 entonces
vamos a tener aquí menos 1
- 101 y vamos a restar vamos a restar de
hecho este uno entre raíz de dos con
este 1 entre raíz de 2 podemos sacarlo
hasta afuera y al multiplicarlo nos
queda uno entre raíz de dos por uno
entre raíz de dos es un medio verdad
entonces tenemos menos un medio de el
producto punto de estos dos ahora quién
es el producto punto de estos dos
tenemos menos uno por menos uno es 10
por uno es cero y uno por cero es cero
entonces de hecho todo esto se va a
simplificar a una verdad no nos va a
alterar en mucho y hay que multiplicar
ahora sí por este vector menos 1 10
y lo tenemos aquí entonces vamos a hacer
las operaciones tenemos al menos 101
este 1 pues ya no pinta ahí tenemos que
multiplicar por un medio a todo este
vector entonces nos queda menos 1 por un
medio es menos un medio aquí vamos a
tener un medio por uno es un medio y un
medio por cero es cero y ahora si
restamos coordenada coordenada y tenemos
menos 1 - menos un medio es decir menos
uno más un medio nos queda menos un
medio aquí cero menos un medio es menos
un medio y uno menos cero es uno ok
entonces este vector de aquí es el
vector de 2 que en conjunto con uno ya
generan a todo el espacio b y además
tenemos la garantía de que estos dos
lectores son ortogonales ahora bien esto
todavía no es una base orton normal nos
falta
escalar este vector de 2 para que tenga
norma 1 y eso es muy sencillo porque de
hecho definimos
como 2 o bueno uno sobre la norma de dos
que multiplica al vector de dos ahora
quién es la norma la norma de ye 2 la
norma de ye 2 es la raíz cuadrada de la
suma de todas sus de la suma de los
cuadrados de sus coordenadas entonces
aquí es un cuarto verdad menos un medio
al cuadrado es un cuarto menos un medio
al cuadrado es un cuarto y uno al
cuadrado es uno muy bien entonces aquí
tenemos un cuarto más un cuarto que es
un medio más uno que son dos medios
entonces tenemos simplemente la raíz de
tres medios entonces este 22 va a ser 1
entre la norma que es uno entre la raíz
de tres medios que también lo podemos
expresar como 2 sobre 3 y le sacamos
raíz cuadrada que multiplica a nuestro
vector menos un medio
- un medio uno ok y esto en conjunto con
el 1 que ya habíamos encontrado que de
hecho era 1 sobre la raíz de 2 por el
vector menos 110 verdad estaba acá
arriba aquí está el vector 1
estos dos vectores en conjunto es decir
si formamos el conjunto que tiene a1 y
a2 es una base corto normal corto normal
de nuestro espacio vectorial inicial ve
que está definida por esta ecuación
verdad que era un plano
entonces ya hemos terminado hemos usado
el proceso de grandes mid y estos estos
vectores de aquí abajo el 1 y 2 son
nuevos vectores de una base orton normal